up next for HBO Lily Rose Dev stars in a
controversial new series the idol
premiering Sunday I sat down with a star
who gave a show of support for her
famous father Lily Rose your dad of
course Johnny Depp he's also at cam this
year and he received a rousing standing
ovation what do you think that really
meant to your father I'm super happy for
him I'm super excited and it's you know
it's so awesome that we both get to be
here with projects that we're super
proud of Lily and John missed each other
on the crossettes by six days his film
got a seven minute standing o her
premiere had the audience clapping for
fun so where did you start Lily portrays
of Hop star fresh off a nervous
breakdown she seduced by Abel the
weekend teslave playing a modern day
cult leader but contrary to rumors Lily
told me her character is not based on
Britney Spears who were you actually
thinking of when you were creating this
woman of course there's so many
incredible pop stars of of today that I
that I you know have nothing but
admiration and respect for and we're
definitely not telling anybody else's
story we actually from a lot of other
influences we thought a lot about Sharon
Stone in Basic Instinct I go with the
flow Los Angeles is where all the
monsters of the world come together the
idol has been surrounded by controversy
critics have described it as revenge
porn and 50 Shades of Tess Bay as for
reports there was chaos on set he's
brainwashed her
what do you make it for the weekend he's
such a kind and generous person uh we
literally filmed in his house he really
is such a great learner of The Craft
along with the weekends there are other
real life musicians in this cast Troye
Sivan and Jenny from blackpink
[Music]
Jenny you are literally a K-pop Idol so
did you give Lily any advice when it
came to performing as Jocelyn and we did
have this conversation like long time
ago I actually got to see a blackpink
and Jenny live not that long ago and it
was so much fun I had the best time ever
what was the name of that club
the Lily beer portrayal is incredible
because even down to your run and
whenever you're filming the music video
it's like oh my God you've even got the
pop star run down that's how I run and
yeah can I just I guess I just couldn't
I couldn't quite step out of myself for
that one but thank you thank you very
much
[Music]